يفجيني بريغوجين من موالد لينينغراد
بروسيا ويبلغ من العمر 62 عاما سجين جنائي
سابق ابان حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 81
حكم عليه بالسجن 12 سنه وذلك بتهم السرقه
والاحتيال امضى منها تسع سنوات قبل اطلاق
سراحه وبعد خروجه عام 90 تطورت اعماله
وسرعان ما اسس شركه كونكورد للطعام التي
للمفارق حصلت على مئات الملايين من العقود
الحكوميه سمحت له علاقاته وتكفل شركته
بحفلات الكريملين بتوثيق علاقاته بالرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حتى سمي طباخ بوتين
وكان الغموض يلف طبيعه علاقته
بالاستخبارات والدفاع الروسيه شكل تاسيس
مجموعه فاجنر وهي مجموعه شبه عسكريه
واصبحت مملوكه له ايذانا بمرحله جديده في
مساره مجموعه فاغنر بدات تظهر على المشهد
في روسيا عام
2014 بعد ضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرم افتتحت
رسميا اول مقر لها في مدينه سان بترسبورغ
الروسيه وقال بريغوجين ان مهمه مركز فاجنر
الرئيسي توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد افكار
جديده لتحصين القدره الدفاعيه لروسيا لم
يخفي ذلك اتهامات لفاجنر بارسال مسلحيها
الى دول عربيه واخرى في امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا وتنفيذ ما توصف بالعملي القذره
في مناطق النزاعات المختلفه خلال حرب
اوكرانيا تضخم عدد مقاتل فاغنر تفجر
الصدام بين وجين والمؤسسه الرسميه الروسيه
منذ العام الماضي وشكلت المعركه على
سليدار الاوكرانيه والتي انتهت مطلع يناير
كانون الثاني الماضي مؤشرا على حجم
الخلافات قبل ان تبدا شكاوى المجموعه بعدم
تزويدها بالسلاح وامدادات الذخيره الكافيه
مع تهديد بالانسحاب من باخ
موت اتهم بيكوجين وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان بمحاوله تدمير المجموعه وعرقله
وصول المتطوعين وقال ان روسيا قد تواجه
ثوره ممثله لثوره عام 17 وتخسر الحرب في
اوكرانيا وفيما بدا خطوه لتقليص نفوذ
المجموعه جاء قرار وزير الدفاع الروسي في
العاشر من يونيو الماضي الزام جميع
التشكيلات المتطوعين الروس بتوقيع عقد مع
وزاره الدفاع حتى الاول من يوليو تموز رد
بيكوجين لم يتاخر برفض التوقيع وفي الث3
من يونيو الماضي اتهم القياده العسكريه
الروسيه بقتل عاد كبير من عناصره في قصف
استهدفهم وتعهد بالرد والانتقام وطالب
براس كل من وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان بعد
ذلك انسحبت قوات من فاغنر من اوكرانيا
واحتلت مدينه روستوف على نهر الدون
الروسيه وتوجهت الى موسكو وجهت تهم جنائيه
ضد بريجين من قبل جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي للتحريض على تمرد المسلح واعتبره
بوتين خيانه لروسيا وطعنه في الظهر رد
بريجين بالقول ان بوتين كان مخطئا للغايه
عندما وصفهم بالخونه وبعد محادثات بينه
والرئيس البيلاروسي اسقطت التهم واوقف
بريغوجين مسيره قوته نحو موسكو تحدثت
تقارير عن استقراره لبعض الوقت في
بيلاروسيا لكن رئيسها ذكر لاحقا ان
بريغوجين ليس موجودا في بلاده ظهر قبل
ايام في مقطع فيديو نشره على قناته في
تليجرام ملمحا فيه الى انه موجود في
افريقيا ضمن انشطه الاستطلاع والبحث مما
يجعل روسيا اكثر قو في كل القارات وفق
تعبيره ليعلن في الثال عش من اغسطس الجاري
سقوط طائره شمال موسكو وحديث عن وجود
يفجيني برجين على
متنها